[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Welcome.
My name is Malika Saada Saar.
I'm Google's Senior Council
on Civil and Human Rights.
You know, about a year ago,
the great human rights lawyer
Brian Stevenson came to Google.
Came to our TGIF,
where all of us
come together in Mountain View.
And TGIF is livestreamed
to all of our employees.
And so, as a company, we came
together to welcome Brian.
And Brian said to us,
challenged us, to bear witness,
to be proximate to the human
costs of mass incarceration.
And so over the year,
in the last 10 months,
in fact, we have been doing
criminal justice forums
within Google to
really do what Brian
asks us to do-- to
bear witness and to be
proximate to the human
costs of mass incarceration.
We've had these conversations in
different parts of our company.
We've thought about and continue
to ask the question of--
how do we use our platforms
to disrupt mass incarceration?
Because we know that what
we do at Google is disrupt,
disrupt for good.
And if anything needs
to be disrupted,
its the overcriminalization
of our black
and brown communities.
But most of how we've
had that conversation
has really been
without the words
and lived experiences
of women and girls.
And so today, as part of
Women's History Month,
we want to be able
to delve deeply
into what is mass incarceration
from the perspective of women
and girls?
When we talk about
achieving racial justice,
how do we do it from
a gendered lens?
Up to 80% of women
behind bars have
been subject to some
form of sexual violence.
Sexual violence is
the primary predictor
of girls going behind bars.
And women and girls are
the fastest growing prison
populations.
We must have this
conversation as part
of our overall commitment to
disrupting mass incarceration.
We cannot have any real
comprehensive discourse around
criminalization of black and
brown communities without
centering the experiences
of women and girls.
And with that, it is my
absolute honor and privilege
to introduce to you the
founder and Executive Director
of the National
Council for Formerly
Incarcerated and Incarcerated
Women and Girls, Andrea James.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREA JAMES: Hi, everybody.
Thank you.
I'm not going to be labor
anything beyond what Malika
has said.
I cannot underscore enough the
importance of the words that
she did say.
I want to say thank you to
everybody here at Google, both
in this room, and those of
you who are on live stream,
for tuning in to this
incredibly important issue.
And I think, without
me going any further,
you will understand
why it was so
important by the end of
our time here together.
Miss Alice, are you there?
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON:
Yes, I'm here.
ANDREA JAMES: Can
you see me at all?
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: No,
I don't see you right now.
ANDREA JAMES: OK,
well, I love you.
I don't know what
I'm doing here.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON:
I love you, too.
Thank you.
ANDREA JAMES: Topeka's
telling me to do something--
what phone?
Oh, here.
Hi, Miss Alice.
There you go.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON:
Oh, I see you now.
Hi, Andrea.
ANDREA JAMES: How
are you, darling?
OK, so we're going to
begin our conversation.
You are seeing Miss
Alice Marie Johnson.
And I'm going to tell you
very briefly, so that we
can get to Ms.
Johnson, and you're
going to hear from her
for the rest of the time
that we're having our
discussion together,
about the work of
the National Council.
We are a platform that we have
created, really starting out.
Because we knew that our
voices needed to be heard.
Our mantra is nothing
about us without us.
Because we are the experts,
the women and girls who
have gone through
the experiences, who
have been directly affected by
an incredibly unjust, racist,
classist, and discriminatory
criminal justice system,
we are the experts that
need to be at the forefront
and at the table in
creating a policy for--
not just change, not for
reforming a criminal justice
system that we don't believe
can be reformed, but in creating
and shifting radically
to a human justice system
and what that entails.
So the National Council
for Incarcerated
and Formerly Incarcerated
Women and Girls
was created to connect all
of the powerful, brilliant,
courageous, brave, incarcerated
and formerly incarcerated women
and girls across
this country who
are doing that
work as the experts
to create the change that
we know needs to happen.
You're going to hear from
many of them here today.
And you are privileged to have
the voice of the experience
of the women that you will
hear from today, starting
with Miss Alice.
And the Obama
administration started
a project called The
Clemency Project 2014,
obviously it was back in 2014.
And we went to the mat,
under the leadership
of our clemency
expert, Amy Povah, who
was a woman who served years
in the federal prison system
prior to her sentence being
commuted by President Bill
Clinton.
And Amy, we have this thing,
when we leave the prison doors,
and we're walking out the door,
everybody says don't look back.
Don't look back.
It's like a curse.
We love you.
We want to see you go.
Do not look back.
If you look back,
it's like the curse
is going to bring you back.
And so we kind of leave
there, and we don't look back.
Amy Povah looked back.
She never stopped
looking back from the day
that she left that prison when
President Bill Clinton commuted
her sentence.
She started the organization
Can Do Clemency.
And please, check it out.
You are going to see some
of the faces of the women,
including Miss Alice
that are part of that.
Well, unfortunately
or fortunately,
of the very small
number of the thousands
of women that met
President Obama's criteria,
but somehow were left
behind, 50 of our women
did make it out under the
leadership of Amy Povah
and the women of the
council and women
across this country that
went to the mat to fight,
to push these women
out of prison.
Miss Alice Johnson fit those
criteria, unfortunately,
and even though she's been
in a prison for decades,
was not one of the women that
we were able to push out.
And this is incredibly
painful for us.
And I'm going to stop there.
And I'm going to
ask Miss Alice--
Miss Alice, we love you.
We understand how incredible--
Miss Alice is in
a federal prison
speaking to us right now.
And I want you to begin, Miss
Alice, by telling us about you
and about your
story, and why you're
sitting in that federal prison.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: OK.
OK.
My name is Alice Marie Johnson.
And on May 30th of this
year, I'll be 62-years-old.
I've already spent a third
of my life behind bars.
In 1996, my life
drastically changed forever.
I was convicted as a first
time, non-violent drug offender,
and sentenced to life
in federal prison.
I'd always thought that only the
most heinous crimes warranted
a life without parole sentence.
I have the exact same
sentence as Charles Manson.
Prior to coming to prison.
I lived, I guess you could
say, a pretty productive life.
I never expected anything
like this to happen to me.
I had worked in various
professional positions.
I was working at
Federal Express.
I had been a manager
with FedEx for 10 years.
I was also a
facilitator who trained
other people for management.
When I lost my job at
10 years with Fed Ex,
I can tell you that
my life literally
began to spiral out of control.
I made one of the worst
choices that I've ever
made in my life,
which I deeply regret.
I became involved in
a drug conspiracy.
I had never sold drugs.
I had never used drugs.
And I can tell you, I
literally got in over my head.
But I tell you, I made
some very different choices
when I came to prison.
I want to tell you real quickly,
when I was a young girl,
I had someone ask
me, Alice, what
do you want to be
when you grow up?
And I said, I wanted to
be an incredible woman.
They said, what is
an incredible woman?
I said, it's a
woman who goes down
in history, who makes
changes in life,
who makes their print in life,
and impacts people's lives.
That's the kind of woman
that I wanted to be.
I decided when I came to prison,
that because I was in prison,
prison bars don't have
to contain your dreams.
I still wanted to be
an incredible woman.
So I looked around
my new environment
to see how I could impact the
society in prison for good.
So I started serving
others and making
a difference in their lives.
I picked up my pen
and I started writing
plays, plays that were the
largest inmate participation
programs in the prison.
People who thought they
couldn't do anything,
they learned how to do
theatrical productions.
They learned how to act.
I started choreographing dance.
I found people that
the gift of artistry
was stirred up in them, and
beautiful, beautiful backdrops.
And our plays became
just known everywhere.
I also started
mentoring women to see
if I can help be deterred
from a life of crime.
I used the experience that I
had with interviewing and job
preparedness to prepare other
women to go outside and be
productive citizens.
ANDREA JAMES: And
Miss Alice, I want
us to have the
opportunity, Miss Alice,
to talk a little
bit about the fact
that we don't have
available to us right now,
The Clemency Project,
we do not have that.
We have a Justice
Department now that
wants to turn the clocks
back to a place in time that
is dark and draconian
and something that,
with all of the education that
we have learned over the years
and throughout the Obama
administration about the need
to decarcerate--
why, Miss Alice,
you are in a prison,
one of many federal
women's prisons
that are full of
women who are there
and only but for conspiracy
laws in this country that allow
these women to be thrown in and
charged and held responsible
for the same amount
as the person who
is the leader of the drug ring.
Why Miss Alice, why is it
so incredibly important
that we continue and raise
awareness in places like this,
about the need to
push and to continue
to push for the freedom of women
like yourself through clemency?
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON:
Well, conspiracy--
I can say this about conspiracy.
Many of the women in here
were women who did not
have those types of roles.
But they are charged
with leadership roles.
They have to take on
the responsibility
of the entire conspiracy.
Because I was dumb.
I was [INAUDIBLE] because
I had never been in prison.
I didn't even know people
who had served time.
So I didn't know what a
conspiracy charge meant.
It means that you are
charged with every element
of the crime.
You are held responsible
for every act
that anyone else has committed,
whether you had knowledge
of what they were doing or not.
That's why it's
called conspiracy,
so it becomes a catch
all for everything.
And these women, most
of them are mothers.
I'd say 95% of them are mothers.
And I tell you, we
know that women,
not to say anything
about the men,
but the mother is the
nucleus of the family.
When a mother is taken out
of the home, so many times
the family is split apart.
When a man is taken
out of the home,
the woman will hold it down.
But when the women, most of the
time, and it's just the truth--
the children are sent away
to live with relatives,
foster care, and too many times
they are sent to the streets
to be raised that the streets.
And the cycle of
incarceration continues.
So this cause of women and
girls is saving the families.
ANDREA JAMES: Now Miss Alice,
you were a mother, Miss Alice.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: Yes.
ANDREA JAMES: And you're--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: Yes.
ANDREA JAMES: You were a mother,
and you know directly what
that is like to be a mother
who is incarcerated for all
of the years that you
have been imprisoned,
and I want to just,
again, commend
you Miss Alice for
your courage to still
stay with us, as part of the
team, to raise awareness.
Because it must have been
incredibly difficult to have
an opportunity, through
The Clemency Project,
to maybe gain your
freedom, something that you
deserved, a lot of
skin in the game.
We weren't asking for any
favors on your behalf.
You earned your freedom.
And yet to have been denied, I
know it was difficult for us.
We still are challenged with it
every single day, Miss Alice.
We are here, as your team,
fighting to bring you home.
But why is it important
that we use our voices
to encourage this administration
and future administrations
to use clemency to push
women like yourself out
who deserve to come home?
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON:
The fact is there
is no parole in the
federal system--
for most of us, for me,
clemency has been our only hope.
So to not push for clemency
is to take away their hope.
Because we have exhausted
all of the means.
I have not been sitting still.
I have filed motion after
motion in the court.
But clemency, in itself, is an
act of mercy and forgiveness.
And when you see a
person like myself
who has did a complete
turn around in their life,
who has gotten--
I've gotten so much support.
My family fought so hard.
The Clemency Project was
like putting a carrot,
and then drawing it back.
Because we all had so
much hope that that
was going to come
through, because I
knew I fit the criteria.
But as you see, I'm left
behind and I'm still here.
And this is what I
want to say to Google.
Google is a company that
has been greatly blessed.
To whom much is given,
much is required.
When you use your
voice, people listen.
When you champion a cause,
our leadership listens.
You may say am I my
brother's or sister's keeper?
And I say to you to that,
if not you, then who?
If not now, then when?
I don't want to die in prison.
To say later may
be too late for me.
I'm already 62.
I've already spent
two decades in prison.
So I believe that as
responsible citizens we do
have a responsibility
to each other.
We do.
It is not just a
social issue that you
put on an agenda that
sounds good on paper.
It's something you
have to take to heart.
When you see me and so
many others like me,
you see I'm just a
representative, a very small
representative.
But there's many
more just like me.
And I don't believe
that the public is safe
because I'm here.
I'm non-violent, and I've
already spent 20 years.
And I've had 100% clear conduct.
I was on pre-trial
bond for two years.
I was trusted enough to be
out on bond after my arrest.
I've proven that I'm
a reformed woman.
But there's still
no help from me,
unless someone takes on
this challenge of helping us
in mass incarceration and using
what you have been gifted with,
a blessed company.
We need you, and I
would appreciate it
if you would help us.
ANDREA JAMES: Thank
you, Miss Alice.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREA JAMES: Miss
Alice, as we always
do, we want to remind
you that we are here.
Your team is out here.
We will never-- we are here.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: Thank you.
ANDREA JAMES: And you know
that we are going to continue.
And we are going to continue
to do this work, hopefully,
by raising the
consciousness level of what
you have described perfectly--
an incredible organization
here at Google and the power
and the brilliance
that they have,
that we hope that
they recognize,
not that they are
special people,
but they are privileged.
And people who are privileged
to have a responsibility
to the rest of the human race.
So I thank you again for again
coming with us on the road
and sharing what is
so very difficult
and to let everybody understand.
When I hang up this phone
call with Miss Alice,
I'm going to go and
I'm going to sit down
and I'm going to listen to the
rest of the women and girls who
are here with us today.
Miss Alice is going to go back
to a prison, into a prison cell
that she has been in
for more than 20 years.
We need to bring her home.
And we hope that all
of you here at Google
will help us to do that.
Thank you, Miss Alice.
We love you.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: Thank you.
I love you, too.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm going to call
your Topeka up here,
because I don't know what I'm
supposed to do now, Miss Alice.
But we know that you
like to hang out.
And Topeka, what
am I doing here?
OK.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: OK.
ANDREA JAMES: OK.
We're going to get to
let you hang out there.
And Miss Alice is
going to cut off
when she cuts off,
because she is calling
from a federal
prison, and they only
get a tiny window
of opportunity.
But we like to let her hang
out and listen for as long
as she can, because it's like
giving her a break from being
in the prison.
So I love you, Miss Alice,
we're going to move on.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON:
OK, I love you.
And I love you, Malika.
I love you--
ANDREA JAMES: Topeka, Miss
Alice is speaking to you.
TOPEKA SAM: She's
talking to Malika.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON:
Malika and Topeka.
ANDREA JAMES: Oh, Malika.
Right there.
Topeka, Malika, you know what?
OK.
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: Malika
and Topeka, I love you.
Thank you.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: We
love you, Miss Alice.
I'm going to ask--
ALICE MARIE JOHNSON: Thank you.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: --the women's
panel to come and join us.
So we want to focus on
the experience of Women
Behind Bars, and Miss Alice
did a powerful, powerful job
in helping us to begin to
understand that more deeply.
And we are so honored
and privileged to have
your voice, Miss Alice.
And we're going to make
sure that your voice is
heard through all the
corridors of Google.
I want each of you to
introduce yourselves and then
let's start our conversation.
MIYHOSI BENTON: Thank Thank
you, Malika and Google
for having us be a part of this
conversation, a conversation
that's definitely necessary
and crucial at this time.
My name is Miyhosi Benton.
I'm with the Women
in Justice Project.
And pretty much we [INAUDIBLE]
leadership so it directly
impacted women to shift
the dynamic change
to allow the criminal justice
system to be dismantled.
TOPEKA SAM: Good afternoon.
My name is Topeka Sam.
I am the National
Organizer for the National
Council for Incarcerated
and Formerly
Incarcerated Women and Girls.
I'm a formerly
incarcerated woman.
And I'm also the founder of
the Ladies of Hope Ministries.
And our goal at the
National Council
is to end the incarceration
of women and girls.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: So I
wanted to ask each of you
to talk in more depth around how
mass incarceration has impacted
you directly.
MIYHOSI BENTON: So mass
incarceration-- so like,
I was arrested at the age of 19.
I was two months pregnant.
And I did a total of four
years in three different states
New York, New Jersey,
and Pennsylvania.
And while incarcerated, I
gave birth to my daughter
at the Bethel Hills
Correctional Facility,
which is the maximum
facility in New York state.
And I spent many
birthdays behind bars.
And when you think about
your 21st birthday,
you really don't think
about celebrating it inside,
behind the cell, with the
women you barely know.
But you make the best of it.
And as women we make the
best of our situations.
I was also fortunate to be
able to go into the nursery.
Bethel Hills
Correctional Facility
has a nursery where they
allow the woman to stay
with their children
up to a year.
And I was able to
bond with my daughter.
And after I sent her
home, they transferred me
to Albion Correctional Facility,
which is the medium security
facility in New York state
on the borderline of Canada.
And from there, I didn't
receive another visit
from neither one of my children.
Because I had a son that was one
years old when I went inside.
And this is not like
a unique situation.
75 percent of women that
are incarcerated at the time
are moms.
And I was one of those
moms that was far away
and did not have access to
being able to see my children.
And speaking on a
phone or letters
don't cut it when you
have young children,
and they don't cut
it for any children,
because you're not
afforded the bond that you
need to nurture and
to bring them up.
So after my four years,
I came home and reunited
with my son and my daughter.
[APPLAUSE]
TOPEKA SAM: So my impact
with incarceration
has started just being an
African-American woman.
Family members and things
that have been incarcerated
are friends.
But my family, my parents, they
were entrepreneurs, franchise
owners.
And they had us
living in the area
where we were the
only black family.
And partly, it was to
protect us from what was
happening within the country.
And the things that
they went through,
being from New York City.
And when I went off
to go to college
is when I got exposed directly
to different things that
were really happening
in the world,
and started making
poor choices and really
buying into the narrative
of what being black
looked like in America.
And that entailed
dating guys who
may have been drug dealing
and things of that nature.
And then not even
understanding what
had happened in this country
to even cause it to happen
within our communities.
So I had gotten in trouble, and
I would get arrested, and then
go on probation.
And it was a cycle.
Yet still in college and
still maintaining employment
and building a career
or starting a business.
And so when I was incarcerated
in federal prison,
I was incarcerated
for 3 and 1/2 years.
And part of what Miss
Alice spoke about,
and what Miyhosi
just touched on,
was the fact that I had met so
many women who had children.
And so many women in
the federal prison--
we are taken far, far away.
In the Northeast,
Danbury, Connecticut
was the only women's
federal prison.
And I was camp designated,
so I was in Danbury.
And you had women from all
up and down the East Coast
and Midwest who were there.
Yet I would be in
the visiting room,
and there would be no one there.
And partly, it's because
you had the parents, who
were home, who are elderly on
fixed incomes, who were taking
care of the children and
had to choose whether or not
they could have the children
go to see their parents
or feed the children and
make sure that they were OK.
And in then meeting women
who had had already done
20 years in prison,
I knew at that point
that it was my
responsibility to then take
what it was that I learned, even
being impacted by a conspiracy
charge, and by the grace of God,
I did not get life in prison.
But those conspiracy
laws are just that.
I had no drugs in
my case at all.
Yet I was charged with
having 80 kilos of cocaine.
So when you look at
just how that law is
and what is in place and what
it does to our communities,
specifically women and girls.
One of the policies in
the reform that we're
doing at the National Council is
to change that conspiracy law.
So now as a national organizer,
we go around the country.
We are mobilizing, hoping to
get 100,000 members, which
includes formerly incarcerated
and incarcerated women,
directly impacted children
of incarcerated parents,
and people like you who are
movement family and allies who
can help us in moving this work
and getting the message out
so that we can end the
incarceration of women
and girls.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
So, Topeka, I want
to just surface
more of what you're
talking about with the
conspiracy charges.
Because we know,
right, that most women
who are behind bars
at federal and state
correctional facilities
are mothers to children
under the age of 18.
We know that most women
and mothers behind bars
are first time,
nonviolent felons.
What is going on with
the conspiracy charges--
that first time
nonviolent felons,
who are mothers to children
under the age of 18,
are being put behind bars for
20 years or a lifetime sentence?
Can you explain that more to us?
TOPEKA SAM: Absolutely.
It's happening because
it's a retaliation tactic.
It's used because, if
you don't cooperate
in whatever the charges
are-- and a lot of times
the women really have
no idea what's going on.
I mean think about you.
Do you really know what your
boyfriend or your husband
is doing when they leave you?
You don't.
And so they want you to then
speak on information that you
don't-- make up information,
it's people that you may not
have even met in the conspiracy.
Yet, if you don't
cooperate, you end up
getting hit with-- as Miss
Alice described-- everything
that's in that charge.
And then you ending
up in life in prison
because of the sentencing
guidelines and the guidelines
chart.
And the fact that
you are charged
based on the amount of
drugs that is said to have--
not actually have.
So they call it ghost dope.
You don't even have to find it,
yet you'll be charged with it.
And that's how the system
is being manipulated
and so many women and girls
are being caught and swept
into the conspiracy.
And yet it's really a conspiracy
against our women and girls.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Do you
want to add to that, Miyhosi?
MIYHOSI BENTON: Um, no.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: I'm going
to ask you a different question
to add to, but but I just
want to make sure that people
understand what you've said.
Because this is really
one of the key ways
that when we talk
about the war on drugs
and the over prosecution of
black and brown communities
and the overcriminalization
that has happened,
these conspiracy
charges are at the heart
of how we talk about the war
on drugs' devastating impact
on our communities.
But often what doesn't
get talked about
is the particular ways
that it's played out
in the lives of women.
So Miyhosi, I wanted
to talk to you
about this issue of conditions
of confinement for our women
and mothers.
When I was heading up an NGO
on gender-based violence,
some women who were
previously incarcerated
talked to me about how
they had been, during labor
and childbirth, shackled.
And I thought they
were explaining to me
like some crazy thing that
was an aberrant violation
of practice and policy
at a southern prison,
because they were
coming from Tennessee.
And I started to find out
that actually shackling women
during labor and childbirth
is standard procedure.
It was standard procedure in
all of our federal correctional
facilities.
Fortunately, we were
able to change that.
It remains standard procedure
in most of our state prisons.
So let me be clear
in what I am saying.
When a woman behind
bars who is pregnant
is in labor and childbirth,
she is shackled.
She's shackled by
her arms, her legs.
I heard one case of a
belly shackle during labor.
Can you talk to us
more about this policy
and the incredible work that
you've done to change it?
MIYHOSI BENTON: So I
was one of those women.
I was illegally shackled.
In New York state, we
had a law, a 2009 law
that banned the barbaric
shackle in a pregnant women.
When I went in 2009,
I was pregnant.
I gave birth to my
daughter in 2010.
And when you're inside,
you don't know your rights.
And that's one of the
ways they control you.
By not allowing you
to educate yourself
or to educate you on
what your rights are.
So the less you know,
the best for them.
So I didn't know that it was
illegal to shackle me while I
was in labor or delivering.
And my experience, where I was--
so just imagine, for me, like
for anyone, giving birth--
like a joyous moment,
a moment that you're
supposed to be with your
loved ones, your family,
sharing and welcoming
a new life--
and that moment being
distorted and corrupted
by a correctional
officer who doesn't
have any good
intentions towards you.
It's malicious energy.
And for me, while
I was giving birth,
I had the correction officer
standing between my legs
while pushing, while
the doctor was pushing.
And you know, you
want to say something.
And you want to like,
try to understand
how can someone in their
right mind think it's OK.
Like, how is this
humanly possible
that anyone in the world
would think it's OK for you
to stand where I'm trying
to deliver my baby?
And not only put
my life at risk,
but my child's life at risk?
So you not only strip me
of my dignity, my respect,
my self-worth, but you going
to put my life in danger
and my child's life in danger?
So for me that was
a really hard part.
And then the correctional
officer and the doctor
was arguing, because the
doctor did understand
like, this is my job.
This was her job
to deliver the baby
and make sure the mom
and the baby was OK.
And she couldn't do
her job to the best
of her abilities because
of the correction officer.
But after I gave birth,
they automatically
handcuff you right away.
Like, you don't really
even have a moment to bond
with your child,
not to feed them,
not to just hold them and
take in that precious moment.
And when you give
birth, they send you
to Westchester Medical Center.
So you are in a prison ward
inside a Westchester Medical
Center.
And then they bring you in, they
shackle and they handcuff you.
And they may allow you
to see your child maybe
once or twice, if you're lucky.
But in that process, once
again you're shackled
and you're handcuffed,
and it's the metal
chain around your waist,
and it's the handcuffs,
and it's the ankle shackles.
And then you're brought into a
wheelchair to see your child.
And they remove
just the handcuffs.
So you literally cannot
walk with your child.
And all of these things
are illegal at the time,
and no one is held
accountable for these things.
So it is OK for us to be put
into the criminal justice
system for breaking the law.
But it's OK for the
Department of Corrections
to break it day in and day out.
Why?
Because they do not
value our lives.
Black girls, women-- our
lives are not valued--
not in society, not in the
current administrative system
that we have right now,
not inside a prison.
Our lives are not valued.
And it was just
another reminder.
So after I went through
that whole process
of being traumatized and
humiliated and just--
I thought, like, when I come
home, I have to speak up.
Because if we don't
speak up, the ones who
are being criminalized, the
ones who are being dehumanized,
if we don't speak
up, then who will?
It's our stories.
We're the ones who
are experiencing
these horrific
injustices all the time.
So I came home, and I met
with [INAUDIBLE] Tamar,
who was at the correctional
association at the time.
And they came up to me
and was, like, well,
were you illegally shackled?
And I was like, I was.
Like, I was so excited
that there was something--
and there was
organizations and people
out there that cared
and were fighting it.
So I got involved.
And what we did, we spoke
to legislators at Albany.
We had letters.
We dealt with the media.
We did interviews,
and we rallied outside
of the governor's office.
We fought and fought.
We made films about
the experience
of what we had to go through.
And we was able to have
this progressive law pass.
So it reinforced the 2009 law.
And it also expanded it so your
whole pregnancy you were not
allowed to be shackled
and handcuffed at all.
And you had the
privacy of not having
to worry about a correctional
officer being inside
your room while giving birth.
It expanded so much.
[APPLAUSE]
And New York state
now has the most
progressive anti-shackling
law in the country.
And it's because a woman
directly impacted speaking up
in collaboration with allies.
And that would not
have been possible
if it was not for the chances
that we had to speak our piece
and to make it right.
And we have to continue to
do this for any injustice
that we witnessed
or that we bear.
[APPLAUSE]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
Thank you for your work.
Topeka, we are at
this incredible moment
around how, finally, it's
a bipartisan conversation
on ending mass incarceration.
Finally, we have
Republicans and Democrats,
and in the public square,
talking about the war on drugs
was an egregious
violation of human rights.
Finally, we are saying that
mass incarceration must end.
But the women who
have been locked up,
who are still behind
bars, like Miss Alice,
are not part of
these conversations.
What needs to happen
in order to make sure
that at this critical
moment of reform
the women are not left behind?
TOPEKA SAM: Well, what needs to
happen is what's happening now.
Women like you, who are
in these spaces, who
are making it necessary, and
are committing to this work
to allow us, those who have
been directly impacted,
to have our seat at the table.
Our mantra at the council is
nothing about us without us.
And so that's because, as
Andrea had said earlier,
we are the experts.
And how do you know
what we need if you
don't ask us and
engage us in changing
these laws and these policies?
And as Miss Alice said, I
just want to reinforce that,
if not you, then who?
You can't look to your neighbor
or look to someone else
and say that it's
their responsibility.
As humans in this world,
it is our responsibility
and commitment to
one another in order
to make sure that
we are shifting this
to this disgusting
criminal justice system
into a more human
justice system.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
Miyhosi, I want to ask you,
as we get ready to
end this panel, what
needs to happen to make
sure that the stories,
the lived experience,
and expertise of women
is part of our conversation
on racial justice?
MIYHOSI BENTON: I
think before we even
say what needs to
be happening, I
think we need to
recognize and acknowledge
what has been happening.
So women on the inside always
played leadership roles.
They made change when
change was needed.
In New York state, I can
speak for New York state,
in New York state, women
brought college back.
They had the first
HIV education program,
which was modeled across
the whole country.
They also had the children
center and parenting centers.
These are the kind
of things that women
did before coming out.
And then now, they're out,
and they still fighting.
So I feel like we
just need to keep
in mind these are the women we
need to have at the forefront.
These are the women that had the
experience and the expertise.
And these are the
women that are going
to be change agents
to shift away
from that perpetual
punishment paradigm
to one of accountability,
transformation, and healing.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
So when I talked
about this panel to some folks,
the response was, well, so,
where's the policy
person, or the lawmaker?
And I said, right here.
Right?
You all are the
ones that we need.
And we so desperately,
desperately need your voices.
And we're deeply
honored at Google
to be able to have you here.
TOPEKA SAM: Thank you.
MIYHOSI BENTON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARQUESHA BABERS:
Hello, everyone.
Hi.
My name is Marquesha.
I'm going to be doing a
poem for you guys today.
It's called "Imprisoned."
And it's about more than just
being imprisoned physically.
It's about being in a prison
emotionally and mentally.
So here I go.
It's called "Imprisoned."
Imprisoned in a dark and gloomy
chamber, I am imprisoned,
my feet chained together,
hands chained behind me.
I'm afraid of what might happen
if I fight, so I sit silently.
Imprisoned in a dark and gloomy
chamber, I am imprisoned.
Mouth taped shut
so I can't scream.
I close my eyes and
sleep, so I can dream.
Imprisoned in a dark and gloomy
chamber, I am imprisoned.
Hands and feet chained together
with suffering, depression,
and doubt.
But it doesn't take much to
break these chains and get out.
Imprisoned in a dark and gloomy
chamber, I am imprisoned.
Mouth taped shut with
words I can't speak.
Words like I am smart.
I am pretty.
Words like release me.
No longer imprisoned in a
dark and gloomy chamber,
no longer am I imprisoned.
I've found the key to remove
these chains from my hands
and feet.
I'm not afraid to fight you,
fear, so don't challenge me.
No longer imprisoned in a
dark and gloomy chamber,
no longer am I imprisoned.
Cut this tape from my mouth
so I can scream and shout.
It's a great thing when you
make a reality out of a dream.
No longer imprisoned in a
dark and gloomy chamber,
no longer am I imprisoned.
I stand fearless, no longer
imprisoned in a dark and gloomy
chamber, I stand worthy.
No longer imprisoned in a
dark and gloomy chamber,
I stand peaceful.
No longer imprisoned in this
dark and gloomy chamber,
no longer am I imprisoned.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANA KASPARIAN: Hello, everyone.
My name's Anna Kasparian.
I come from a news background.
I am a reporter and
host at "The Young
Turks," which is a very
progressive online news show.
Thank you.
I just want to take
a minute to thank
the organizers of this event
for giving me the privilege
to be here and to
be part of this,
and also to be inspired by
the resilience of the women
that we've already heard from.
And of course,
there are more women
that we're going to hear from.
In this portion
of the event, I am
going to speak to an
incarcerated woman, Ms. Santra
Rucker, and also her
daughter, Kendia Riley.
And it's more about
the difficulty
of establishing a
relationship, as a woman
who has been incarcerated due to
this egregious justice system,
establishing a relationship
with your family members,
with your children.
We've already heard
about the number
of women who are incarcerated
and do have young children
and have a difficult time
having a relationship with them
as a result of this.
So do we have--
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: We're
going to start with Kendia.
ANA KASPARIAN: Oh, we're
going to start with, OK.
That's great so we're
actually going to start
with Cindia Riley, and--
Kendia Riley.
I apologize.
Sorry about that.
So-- OK, can we sit over there?
OK, great.
Thank you so much for being
here and having a conversation
with me about something
that's so incredibly important
and doesn't get talked
about, honestly,
in the field of work
that I do, in journalism.
So tell me a little
bit about your story.
What is it like establishing a
relationship with your mother?
I know that she was
given a life sentence
when you were two years old.
KENDIA RILEY: So
both of my parents
have been incarcerated with
life sentences since I was two.
So it's kind of
been like a seesaw
between trying to communicate
with the both of them.
And I was raised
underneath my grandparents.
So when my mother went
to prison, obviously,
it was either she gives
me to somebody else,
or I'd be in a
foster home, or just
under the care of somebody else.
So she gave power of
attorney to my grandparents.
And in that time, it was
as if the relationship
between my mother
and my father and I
had been transferred
to my grandparents.
So it was as if they became
my actual, legitimate parents.
And the relationship
that you would typically
have as a child, where I
would maybe talk to my mom
individually or ride in a
car, it ceased to exist.
All of our holidays,
whether it's
Christmas or
birthdays or anything,
we had to go through
it in a visiting room.
Or we never had that
physical relationship,
that caring and nurturing.
That there's just that
availability for both of us
to sit down and be able
to communicate thoroughly
and adequately.
And I think that's
most effective when
it comes to that actual
stable relationship
between the two of you.
Because no matter how much
you talk on the phone--
where you have 15 minute
phone calls that cost $3,
and you have 300
minutes a month.
The way that my father's
visitation is set up
is he can only get
five visits a month.
And out of 365 days, that's
just 60 visits a year.
So not only are we
just restricted,
it's like we can never
have a relationship
with real sentimental value.
Because once my
parents come home,
they don't truly know who I am.
And we have to sit,
and I guess, take that,
and try to build off of it.
And my mother has
a release date now.
So it's 2022.
So it's about five or
six years from now.
But when she comes home, I'll be
freshly graduated from college.
And it will be the both
of us sitting in the room
while I'm an adult, and I'm
a grown woman at this point.
And she's older.
And we're trying to place
ourselves in a situation
where we're getting to know
who each other really truly is.
And it's kind of devastating
for the both of us.
And it's practically traumatic,
because we don't know anything.
And the things that she should
know from me being two or three
and watching me grow
and watching what I like
and what I love, that's absent.
And I don't know
what she truly likes.
Because it's not the
same as if you're
riding in a car
with your parent.
And you sit down,
and you hear a song,
and you say, oh, I like this.
And she says, she likes it, too.
And then we can actually
vibe and enjoy it together,
versus being on the telephone,
and I say, oh, I like this,
and she agrees.
And it's just not the same.
ANA KASPARIAN: I
think a lot of times
when we hear about
incarceration and how
we need to reform our
criminal justice system--
and it's always
funny to me that it's
called the justice system, when
there's such a lack of justice
involved-- we don't really
think about the impact it
has on the family members of the
person who gets incarcerated.
Of course, it's a mass
injustice for the person who's
incarcerated, but
also the family
members who are torn from their
mothers and their fathers.
And so I came across an event
that you actually spoke at,
where you talked
about the first time
that you had physical
contact with your mother.
And I thought that
it was so incredible.
And it shared a perspective
that I don't think
most people really know about.
So can you talk about
that a little bit?
KENDIA RILEY: So
I was speaking on,
I can't remember
what event it was,
but my grandmother,
when I was younger,
she used to take me to
all the different places.
And my mother was first
in Danbury, Connecticut,
and we were living in Virginia.
So that was also
not even the hike.
We had a fixed income, as
Topeka spoke of earlier.
So it was hard to travel,
hard to actually get
that money to go there.
So Mother's Days we would
go when I was younger.
But when I became older, it
became a lot more difficult.
We had a lot more
responsibilities.
And I didn't realize--
and it was over this
past summer that I
went to go visit her in June.
And I hadn't realized
that I hadn't
seen my mother for 10 years.
And when I went to go
visit her, the only thing
I could remember was
the smell of her hair
and just sitting in the
visiting room seeing
how happy and excited
she was to see me
and then watching everything
just unfold, from the fact
that the last time she
had actually seen me I
was eight or nine years old.
And I was little.
I was innocent.
I hadn't been through all the
traumatic events and turmoil
that I had endured
at that point.
So looking at her was like
looking at a complete stranger.
And I couldn't remember
how she looked.
And just looking
at her, and telling
my aunt, who visited
with me, and just saying,
wow, we really do look alike.
And just kind of looking
into her eyes and thinking,
I've never seen you
past a photograph.
Or I've never heard your voice
constantly in front of me,
like actually going
through my ears other than
through like the
static of a telephone.
And I think sitting there and
smelling her and just taking me
back to the innocence
of my childhood
and just remembering
that I'm in this, that I
was in the same exact
predicament as I was then.
ANA KASPARIAN: How
has your experience
with having an incarcerated
mother impacted your future?
Because in every sense of the
word, you are a success story.
You have a successful
academic career,
and you've persevered
through what
most people would stereotype
as something that's impossible,
right?
So can you talk to me a
little bit about that.
KENDIA RILEY: So I feel as
though, with the incarceration
of both of my
parents, it's embedded
like a sense of determination
within me, that's kind of--
I feel if they hadn't
been incarcerated,
it wouldn't be as stable
in there as it is.
Because when I was younger,
when I was in elementary school,
they said that I had
behavioral issues.
And it was maybe--
I was in multi-age,
which is a combination
of first and second
grade, and I would act up.
I would threaten my teachers.
I would do all of the above.
And one day, I wrote a letter
to my teacher threatening her,
and they had to get a police
officer to come into the room.
And he had to tell me that
threatening was a felony
and that basically it
was just irrefutable,
you can't do that type of thing.
And my dean stopped and
said, you're so smart.
I don't understand why.
Why are you doing it?
And I told him that I
wanted to go with my parents
and be with my parents.
And I thought getting in trouble
would place me in a situation
where I go to prison
with the both of them.
And then he explained
that it would either
get me in juvenile
detention or I'd
have to go to Merrimack,
which was the main institution
in Virginia.
And it was like
that day forward,
I knew that it was
physically impossible for me
to be with them at all times.
And it just set a standard
for me and an expectation
that, I naturally had
the ability to do well,
so why not just do well
for the sake of them,
or for the sake of myself?
Because if I-- and like, just
the way the police officer
explained it.
And just saying how
it's not the same.
I'm not going to be in
a facility with them,
and it's not what
I think it to be.
And just thinking
of, oh, I don't
want to end up in that
situation at all or ultimately.
And just trying to be
better and set the stakes.
And let them know, so they
wouldn't have that burden,
where they know their child--
and I know it's a lot of blame
can go on the parents while
they're in prison for what
happens to the children
while they're inside--
and I didn't want to be the one
that ended up on the streets.
And my father when
he was interviewed
for Humans of New York, he
said that I was the exception
for a lot of his children.
And just the fact that
he said I had a brother
that I didn't even know
about, that as soon
as he got in prison
about a year later,
he ended up being killed
because of following
in the footsteps of him.
And he said, it's children like
me that should be the norm.
When they have an
incarcerated parent,
we should still be able
to do well, and still
be able to excel, and
do things differently.
So I feel like my
future is impact
because it gives me a role.
And it gives me,
not only which I've
found my voice because of
Topeka, I found my voice truly
and honestly.
Because I had never spoke about
it until I came to a point
where I was so destitute
and by myself and alone.
And I was just hurting.
And it was everybody that
my mother had left me
with had passed away.
So I was 18.
Living by myself,
about to go to college.
I was, like, there
was no one to take me.
No one to help me
with that transition.
And it just got to a
point where I had nothing.
I didn't have any money.
And it grew to the point where
I had to go and do everything
by myself.
So when Topeka
came, and said, hey,
would you like to speak on a
panel about how it affects you?
I never really thought about
how it had majorly impacted
my life, and I was numb to it.
And it was just I was
so succumbed to feeling,
like everything was normal.
Oh, I'd go visit them
in visiting rooms.
I'd talk to them on the phone.
It was just seeing
my vulnerability.
And then realizing
that every single time
I spoke it was like I was
learning something different
about myself.
So I feel like from an
educational standpoint,
it shows that you can
practically do anything.
And like Topeka said earlier,
I do a lot of stuff with grace.
So it makes me feel like I'm
powerful, that I'm invincible.
And it makes it really
takes me to a point
where, just because you
don't have your parents,
you still have that
ability to do better and go
beyond what anybody can
tell you that you can do.
[APPLAUSE]
ANA KASPARIAN: That's amazing.
So I just wanted to quickly
note on "The Young Turks,"
we often bring up the
issue of white privilege,
which, unfortunately, some
of our audience members
get very offended about.
And the reason why I'm
bringing that up right now
is because these are
the types of obstacles
that the disenfranchised have
to persevere through in order
to become success
stories, right?
These are the issues that
I think a lot of people
don't realize occur, that
we have a biased justice
system, that we have
certain obstacles
for certain communities that
people like me don't ever
have to worry about.
And that's the reason why I feel
that it's important for someone
like me to be an ally, to
hear stories like yours,
and do what I can to fight
to reform the justice
system that we have right now.
If there's one final thing
that you would want everyone
to know about how all
of this has impacted you
and your relationship with
your family, what would it be?
KENDIA RILEY: So I think, and
especially over the last couple
of days, that just separating
a mother from her daughter
or father from her daughter
is really just rifting.
And like I said earlier,
it's really numbing.
Where you get to
this point that you
want to know each other so well,
and it seems so impossible,
because there's so many physical
limitations and monetary--
it's just so much stuff where it
takes you away from really ever
having that capability
to establish
a real physical relationship.
And just the idea that, if
you're arguing, if you're sad,
or you're having just a
debate, or just a bad day,
there's no way that you can just
hop up and say, I'm going to go
visit my mom.
You have to sit on
the phone, and then
from every single penny of
every second you're talking,
it's going to either go to waste
or go to a really good cause
of talking on the phone.
And I think more
lately with my mother,
it's been we have
such limited time.
But it's like we're going
and talking back and forth
and battling about what we know
about each other and what we
don't.
And just to sit back and
think, if you were home,
we wouldn't have to do this.
Or to think about other
daughters that might not
have the maturity that
I have or might not
have that ability to even talk.
And I just think that it's
unfair to the children,
and it's just
unfair to all of us
or anybody who can sit and allow
a parent to not be able to be
with their child in some sense.
Or just not to think about
every single stipulation
that surrounds being
with their child.
And just thinking, if you
have a child yourself,
and you take yourself and
separate them, and put them
in a room, and you guys are just
divided by these four walls,
and you have no way of
communicating with each other
without her sliding $1
under the door or $5
for a limited amount of time.
And just thinking about how you
could build that relationship
or how that could taint you.
And it's just not, I
don't think that when
they are making the policies
and the legislation around it,
they don't think about
us as the children.
They think about the crime.
But they don't put in place
that you're hurting us as well.
While my mom's in prison,
that puts me in prison, too.
So it's not just affecting them.
We both have to live it
together and simultaneously.
ANA KASPARIAN: Thank you so
much for sharing your story.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Before
Kendia leaves the stage,
I want to acknowledge
that not only is
Kendia a powerful, fierce
woman advocate for so
many other girls and boys
whose parents are behind bars,
but Kendia is also a sophomore
at the University of Virginia,
majoring in chemistry and
minoring in astronomy.
[CHEERING]
So because it's our
commitment to bring
in the voices of the
women behind bars,
we have a little bit
of time before we
can bring Kendia's mom
in through the phone.
We can't do it until 2:10.
So before we bring
Kendia's mom onto the call,
I'm going to do two things.
I'm going to ask Andrea James
to join the stage with Kendia
and Ana to help represent, while
we're waiting for Santra Rucker
to join us, to talk about
more the experience of being
a mother behind bars and
that mother-child bond, which
as Ana pointed out, is
rarely talked about when
we have these conversations
around the criminal justice
system.
So I invite you all,
and Ana, thank you
for going with the flow.
KENDIA RILEY: Of
course, my pleasure.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
And before you all
get started on
that conversation,
there are these
pictures that have
been flashing on these screens.
And these pictures are
remarkable paintings
done by women and
girls behind bars
as part of an organization
known as Artistic Noise.
It's a New York-based
organization
that goes into our correctional
facilities, adult and juvenile,
and gives young women and
men and boys and girls
and our elders the chance
to have art in their lives
as an opportunity to express
their emotions, their pain,
and their joy.
So I want to acknowledge
these beautiful paintings
that Artistic Noise has
allowed us to share with you.
ANA KASPARIAN: So
I think it's also
important to maybe focus
a little bit on the types
of laws, like the war on drugs.
And some of the influences
behind those types of policies
that lead to individuals
being incarcerated
for ridiculous reasons.
So since I come from
a news background
and do a lot of reporting
on the justice system
and also policies that
politicians propose,
there are a lot of
financial interests at play
that force, not force,
but influence politicians
to push for sentencing
that's incredibly harsh
related to drug policy or
for mandatory minimums,
things like that.
And so it's not an accident.
What we're seeing in
our justice system
is a direct influence of
things like money and politics,
of private prisons encouraging
our representatives
to pass legislation that would
incarcerate people for profit.
And so I don't want
anyone to think that,
hey, these are people who
are just tough on crime.
It's not being about
tough on crime.
It's about victimizing
people to make a dollar.
And I think that that's an
important issue that everyone
needs to focus on.
The women that we've heard
from today are not criminals.
These are innocent
individuals who
have been victimized by
an injust justice system,
or unjust, I should
say, justice system.
So I can't help but
share my opinion.
I know no one told me that
I should or if I could,
but I can't help myself
because this is something
that I'm very passionate about.
And I really do
want reform here.
Anyway, so thank you
for joining us, Andrea.
So talk to me a little bit
about your experiences.
You've been working in this
line of work for a long time.
And I think it's so
incredibly important.
Can we talk a little bit more
about the positive impacts
that women such as yourself
have had in this space?
ANDREA JAMES: Oh, sure.
I want to dial back
just a little bit, just
so we can just, so we
can touch upon the issues
that Kendia was talking about.
Because as a woman--
so I was a lawyer
who was sentenced
to serve a 24 month
sentence in the federal
prison for women
in Danbury, Connecticut.
OK, I was allowed
to self-report.
I was a lawyer.
We were treated differently.
I showed up in court twice.
Once to hear the charges against
me, and the other to hear what
I was going to be sentenced to.
I negotiated my sentence down
from 63 months to 24 months,
and I went off and
served my 24 months.
I happened to have older
adult children at the time.
But I also had a
12-year-old daughter,
who's currently a sophomore
at Spelman University, Spelman
College.
And I also had a baby boy who
I had just given birth to,
who when I walked
into that prison-- so
my whole family took
me to the prison.
I, again, was
treated differently
than 99% of the women that
I was incarcerated with--
who had not seen their children
since they were looking out
the back window of a
law enforcement vehicle,
and watching their babies
being shuttled away
by some other state actor, OK?
And then I was in
a prison with women
who had not seen their
children for six, seven,
eight years, if they had
seen them at all since they
had been incarcerated.
And the feeling of
what that's like--
my baby boy was five months old.
I did not come home
until he was 2.
This is Santra calling in.
So I'm happy then.
Because I want you to hear
her voice and not mine.
But those are the
very real things
that women who are
incarcerated are dealing with.
And not even being
able to breathe.
I want to leave us
with this point,
that for a woman who
leaves her children behind,
we literally have to put
our children on a shelf
in order to breathe to
get through our sentence.
That is criminal.
OK?
OK.
I can hear you.
ANA KASPARIAN: OK, great.
My name's Ana Kasparian.
Thank you for taking the
time to speak with me.
SANTRA RUCKER: Oh, thank you.
Thank you for
allowing me to speak.
ANA KASPARIAN: So we were just
having a great conversation
with your daughter about some
of the obstacles to establishing
a bond between the two of you.
And we heard her side of
the story, her perspective.
And I was hoping
that we can also
hear your perspective as well.
SANTRA RUCKER: OK, well, it's
like the dynamics of being
incarcerated is really sensitive
when it comes to a mother
and daughter
relationship, because you
don't want your child to have
any type of resentment or anger
because she feels
abandoned or whatever
situation is due to
my circumstances that
led me to come to prison.
You know, these are
the things that I hope.
But people might feel that
it is wrong for me to say,
like I'm not really
remorseful for the things that
led me to come to prison.
In fact, I think that
the greater gravity was
my choice and my poor choices.
At the time, I didn't think
that those choices would affect
my children or my family,
because I was doing the things
that I love to do at the time.
So at the same time, I
don't want to beat myself up
for my past to make
my relationship better
with my daughter because
I can't change the past.
So what I'm doing is I'm trying
to benefit from the past,
and move on.
But in my own belief,
I believe that karma
plays a big part in the
conditions of my imprisonment,
because that's my
personal belief.
But at the same time, I
believe that whatever you are,
and whatever you are
not, you earned it
whether it's good or
bad and whatever you are
or whatever you are not--
SPEAKER 1: This call is
from a federal prison.
SANTRA RUCKER: And
right now I feel like I
have changed dramatically.
And I have [INAUDIBLE] raised
my level of consciousness
to a higher vibration so that
I can be able to be active with
my daughter, to show love for
my daughter, to do the things--
not trying to make
up for my past,
but the things that
a mother would do.
I try to do these things over
the phone, through the emails,
through visitation, sending
things to my daughter
to show her that I
love her and that I
am sorry to not be there.
So in my absence, I do
things from my heart.
[SOBBING]
ANA KASPARIAN: Kendia
talked a little bit
about what it was like to
have physical contact with you
for the first time.
I'm curious to hear what
that felt like for you.
SANTRA RUCKER: It
felt kind of awkward.
Because you don't
know what to say.
Like I wanted to
be a mother, but I
didn't want to act too
overprotective, because
of my absence,
due to my absence.
But I wanted to show her that,
yeah, true, I am your mother.
And I want you to
be open with me.
I want you to
understand me, and I
want you to learn who I
am through visitation,
because we only would
talk over the phone.
And it was kind of a bonding
time, where I looked at her
and she looked at me.
But at the same time, I
didn't know what to say.
I didn't know if I
should touch her.
I didn't know if
she would reject me.
So I watch how other
people in the visitation
interacted with their children.
So that I can learn
that, OK, this
is all right to hold her hand.
This is all right to do this,
or this is all right to do that.
But it was pretty--
it was more emotional
for me when I came back.
Because I was, like, I wish
I would have said this.
I wish I would have said that.
And when she came to
visit me, my other family
was there-- my
sisters, my nephews,
so I couldn't be
as personal as I
wanted to be and say the
things that I really wanted to.
Because it was so long.
It had been 10
years before I had
seen my family and my daughter.
So it was just really hard.
It's even harder when you have
to come back from visitation.
You know and to be around total
strangers that you don't love,
and that you don't know.
You know?
So, I'm sorry.
Can you hear me?
ANA KASPARIAN: Yes,
I can hear you.
Thank you so much for
sharing your story.
It's very moving.
And everyone-- there
are several members
of the audience that are in
tears right now over what
you're saying.
So Kendia has done incredible
things with her life.
She is a sophomore at the
University of Virginia.
She's studying majors
that I can't even
wrap my brain around.
She's an incredible young woman.
So what are your
feelings about that?
SANTRA RUCKER: I'm very proud.
And I feel, sometimes I wonder
if my absence made her life
better.
Because she was raised by
the same parents as me.
That's my mom and dad.
So I knew she would be a
good person, a loving person.
You know, but I'm glad.
I feel like she's the
better side of me.
You know?
Like, I feel like
I couldn't make it.
And I didn't make it.
And I wasn't successful
like I wanted to be.
So I figure that
with her doing it,
it makes me feel proud
because she is me.
She's a part of me.
And I knew that she
would do great things.
And I just always knew that she
had she has great potential.
So I wasn't shocked
that she would
be as productive and intelligent
as she is in everything
that she's displaying.
You know?
So I knew that she would
be all right, you know?
But I often wonder, if
I was home to raise her,
would she have taken that route?
Maybe my poor choices would have
infected her and affected her.
You know, so I was kind of
glad to be absent in a way
so that she could have
the perfect life that I
didn't have.
ANA KASPARIAN:
Kendia shared with us
that you, fortunately,
finally, have a release date.
So I'm curious what
you maybe fantasize
about doing with your family,
doing with Kendia when
you are released.
SANTRA RUCKER:
Well, a lot of times
I see, I listen to a lot
of prisoners that leave.
They make big plans.
And that folder seems
to be somewhere lost
in the attic when they get home.
But I know one of
the biggest problems
that my family faces
is financial problems.
So I've been in
here studying how
to learn the different
grants that's available
when I get out, the different
loans that they have
for convicted felons, and try
to use those things to open up
a restaurant where my
family can benefit from.
And I think finances is of
great importance for everybody
in life.
Because without money, you
can't really do anything.
And I believe that we can
come together as a family
and be productive and have
fun and go places and travel.
And do the things, not
to make up for lost time,
but for the now.
And so I hope to have a
restaurant when I get out.
I took culinary art.
And I taught Kendia how to
bake over this telephone.
So I'm hoping that I can do
that, not just for myself,
but for my family.
That's one of the main things.
And I just want to be a
mother to my daughter.
And those things I have tried
to do from prison, which
I have great limitations here.
But I believe when I get
home, it could be better.
But it depends on my daughter.
Because if my daughter
feels that I abandoned
her or she feels any
resentment, or she feels
any anger towards my
absence, then it's
going to be quite difficult
for me to do the things
that I would love to do and
have the great desire to do.
But it has to be a
mutual agreement.
And I just hope to be the
most successful person
that I can be.
I want to be the person
that I was in 1999 before I
came to prison.
So I have high goals.
I have high standards.
I have high principles.
And I believe, that with
God being in my life,
that these things are
manifesting before I even
come home, you know.
So I'm not waiting
for the manifestation
to take place when
I walk out the door.
I'm preparing it now.
Through my provision,
through my prayers,
and through what I know,
which is my belief.
But I believe that we were
all one, and we'll be one.
It's kind of hard to be
one from prison, because
of the barricades that we face.
But hopefully, I hope that,
through my mom and dad,
that the love that
they instilled
in me, the human
compassion that they
instilled in me,
that they instilled
those things into Kendia.
So when I get home, everything
will be as if I never left.
And that's how I would like it.
That's how I want it to
be when I touch home.
I'm sorry.
I get a little emotional.
ANA KASPARIAN: No, it's OK.
SANTRA RUCKER: But you know,
but you know, I'm sorry?
ANA KASPARIAN: No, go ahead.
SANTRA RUCKER: But you know,
I understand where I am.
I understand the
circumstances of my life.
And the events that took
shape to get me here,
and the people who
I gravitated to.
But during that era of the '80s,
that was like the 'in' thing--
SPEAKER 1: This call is
from a federal prison.
SANTRA RUCKER: --what was
happening at the time.
ANA KASPARIAN: Miss--
SANTRA RUCKER: And the
decision that I made
were what I thought
were good decisions.
It was just normal and typical
for people my age in that area.
ANA KASPARIAN: Miss Santra
Rucker, sorry to interrupt you.
I just want to let you know
that we might lose you soon.
And if we do, I just want
to thank you for your time.
And thank you for speaking
with us and sharing your story.
SANTRA RUCKER: No, and I
thank you for allowing me.
I thank you for having
human compassion,
to be able to be a
sensitive audience.
That-- just take this
as a shift of awareness
and know that, I
just know everything
is going to be all right just
from speaking to you all.
And I think you all can
make a big difference.
And I thank you
again, I really do.
Because you have an
influential power
that can change your life.
And just from the audience
being there today,
this shows that everybody's
destiny and fate can change.
And you could be really
influential and encouraging
to prisoners as well.
Because it's difficult.
It's very difficult.
It's difficult for our children
and for us as prisoners.
But I thank you as well.
Start crying.
ANA KASPARIAN: You have
no reason to apologize.
Please take care of yourself,
and thank you again.
SANTRA RUCKER: OK, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR:
Typical Google,
where I said working at Google's
like understanding jazz.
That you know
somebody's riffing here.
Somebody's riffing there.
So this is also, this
is a very Google-y,
because this is very
much like an act of jazz.
I know that it's a lot to hold
all of the ways in which we are
bearing witness and
being proximate to what
the costs of
incarceration has been
to our mothers
and our daughters.
But I think it's
important to stay present.
Because it's not only
an issue of placing
and overcriminalization
and relegating our women
and mothers to incarceration.
It is also a narrative of what
is happening to our girls.
And there's a lot of
conversation around the school
to prison pipeline.
But there's not conversation
around how the girls fit
into that pipeline.
And how in many ways, the
girls have a separate pipeline
into the juvenile
justice system.
We wanted this panel
to be able to surface
some of the lived experiences
and the lived expertise
around what is
happening to our girls.
So if we could
start with Charity.
If you could each introduce
yourselves and and then
we'll talk about it.
CHARITY CHANDLER-COLE:
Yes, hello, everyone.
My name is Charity
Chandler-Cole.
I am a social justice
advocate, and I
advocate for various
social justice
issues such as criminal
justice reform, human sex
trafficking, and foster care.
And I sit on various
boards and committees
throughout the state that
address these issues.
MICHELLE DIAZ: Hi,
good afternoon.
My name is Michelle Diaz.
I'm an advisor
for the task force
in ending girls'
incarceration in New York
City for Vera Institute.
SARAH ZARBA: Hi,
my name is Sarah.
I'm actually also part
of that task force
and I'm also working at the
Vera Institute of Justice
in New York City.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: So
beginning with Charity,
if you could each
talk about how you
were placed into
the juvenile justice
system and your
experiences there.
CHARITY CHANDLER-COLE:
Absolutely.
So at the age of 10, my mother
was going through a divorce,
and she got breast
cancer at the same time.
And she pretty much
afterwards went
through a state of depression,
stress, and anxiety.
And she basically just gave up
on the six children she had,
and we kind of had to
fend for ourselves.
My older sister entered
the juvenile justice
and foster care system
at the age of 12.
So when I was 14, I
was the big sister.
I was the mother.
And I did everything I could
to provide for my four younger
siblings while we
were on welfare.
At the age of 16, I got caught
stealing underwear from Ross.
Nothing cute, it was Hanes.
You know, from a
sibling, so it was simply
out of a pure desire
of need for my family.
And the police called
my mother to pick me up,
and she said, take her to jail.
And they did.
And my mom at the time used the
foster care system and juvenile
justice system to kind of one
by one get rid of the children
that she no longer desired
to have at the time.
It wasn't because she
just didn't love us,
she just didn't know
how to take care of us
any longer after
what she experienced.
After there, I spent the
next two years in and out
of juvenile hall
and foster care.
No one at any point
asked my mother
why do you want your
child to go to jail?
You know, why is she
stealing underwear?
What situation is
happening in your family
to cause your daughter
to steal underwear?
Here are some alternatives
to incarceration.
I was just-- they said,
OK, they hung up the phone.
They handcuffed me, put me in
the back of their patrol car,
booked me, and took
me to juvenile hall.
I, at that very moment, realized
that my life had zero value,
and that I could easily
be discarded and put away.
My experience in
the juvenile justice
system and the foster
care system were horrid.
And I experienced
and was exposed
to things I probably would
have never experienced
living in the streets in a
gang-infested and drug-infested
neighborhood.
Any ounce of self-esteem
and confidence
I have went out the window,
and I was constantly degraded.
I felt enslaved, and I
was psychologically abused
and sexually exploited
while in the system.
And because of
what I experienced
and because of the feeling of
abandoning the four siblings
that needed me-- who was going
to feed them and take care
of them, who's going to walk
them to school the next day--
just feeling completely
just abandoned, alone,
and worthless, I left
the system determined
that I was going to work my
ass off for the rest of my life
to help change it.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHELLE DIAZ: Well, everything
started when I was 13.
I'm only 20.
I came here.
I did not speak English
at all, and my mother
was working seven days a week.
And the only person that I
knew was my mother, and then
nobody else.
When I went to school, my
school class was only Spanish,
so I didn't really
learn English at all.
And when I was going
to school, I was shy.
I didn't talk to the other kids.
And then one time, I just
went to McDonald's, and I
met this guy.
And you know, he was
much older than me--
keeping in mind
that I was only 13--
and he talked to me.
And you know, like I
said, my mother never
had the time to be with me.
And the reason why I
moved to United States,
it was because I wanted to
have that mother and daughter
relationship, because my mother
all the time, she was working.
And then this guy
who treat me "right,"
quote unquote, who
pay attention to me,
make me being the
idea of being in love.
And one time, like
I was going crazy--
the only person that I
really pay attention to--
and one time we just
went to the mall
and he stole a tee shirt
from JC Penney, 25 bucks.
And we got caught.
And he was like, oh,
Michelle, take the charge.
Take the charge.
They're not going to
do nothing to you.
You're under age.
And I was like, no, it's not
my fault. And he was like,
oh, he started arguing with me.
And of course, you don't want
to be mad with the person--
you don't want the person to
be mad at you, the only person
who's paying attention to you.
So I said, yeah,
I take the charge.
And then I will spend
the night at the prison.
And then my mother
came and took me.
And the next day, I run away.
I went back to him.
And this was like
a family court.
And my lawyer was like, oh,
Michelle, just take the charge.
It's going to be 18
months of probation.
And of course, I did
not know nothing.
I didn't speak English.
My lawyer was only
speak English.
So it was really, really hard.
The interpreter was there
only for like two minutes.
And I was like,
yeah, sure, whatever.
And then one thing
lead to another.
I started missing school.
I got pregnant at 15.
I was in seventh grade, and
like all these things crash.
I run away.
Got a warrant and a
violation of probation.
I went back because I always
wanted to do the right thing.
I always wanted to be somebody.
But never nobody
asked me why I was
doing what I was doing, what I
wanted to be, where am I going,
what is my future, right?
In the end, I went back.
I try, I try to do things right.
But there was no support at all.
And I was a teenage mom.
And I dropped out of middle
school, never graduated.
And I couldn't
take it any longer.
And my probation officer
violated me again.
I ran away.
Then the judge said
that I was a runner,
and he put me in a secure
facility in New York.
And I spent like, about eight,
six to eight months in there.
And after that I went
to a group home close
to home, a secure facility.
And it was when I started
speaking English was when
I was in this secure facility.
Because nobody spoke
Spanish over there.
But I could put together
the images, what I see,
what I hear.
And it was amazing.
But the first time I was
there, I couldn't eat.
Why?
Because I didn't like the food.
I just, I couldn't take it.
Nobody wanted how I lost 10, 20
pounds in a month over there.
And when I got out, I spent
two months in a group home.
But I was always scared.
People talk about Rikers
Island, the secure facility,
and how bad it is.
And I was like, damn, I
don't want to go there.
I was so afraid,
because at that time,
I didn't have papers at all.
And then I was like,
if I do something,
and there was this girl.
She was 15 and
tried to fight me.
And I was like, I
can't get into her.
Because what is next?
Next thing you know, I'm
going to get deported.
And I can't do that,
I have a child.
And I want something.
I wanted to do
something with my life.
And then I got moved to the
foster care system, where I
spent about two years in there.
And I met this amazing work.
And then I met my mentor.
And everything started
being put together.
I went to school,
got my GED, and then
when I was going to
school, it's when
I got to sit down
with people that
had to spend decades of
their lives in prison
and how much they suffer.
And then I would ask them,
why you didn't do something
about it.
Look, but no-- they're
waiting for the other person.
And then I decided
to be that person.
And if there's one thing
that I have to go back to,
I wouldn't change it.
Even though I would love to
have been for my daughter
all this time.
But I am where I am because
of everything that I had done.
And I'm liking myself.
I'm starting to love myself.
[APPLAUSE]
SARAH ZARBA: Just listening
to you ladies, I mean,
it's just echoing
the same thing.
I was 14 the first time that I
was involved with the system.
And I mean, I was in
the back of the police
car, 14 years old,
handcuffed, because
of a fight that
happened at home.
And my parents, I mean,
they stayed together.
They're still together today.
And coming from Long Island,
which is a suburban community,
that's not something
that is the norm there.
So parents of limited resources
on what to [INAUDIBLE],
like, what do you do when
your child is out of control?
Or what do you do when your
kid is skipping school?
And in that case,
the cops were called,
and I was placed in handcuffs.
And the whole ride, at 14, too.
I didn't even know
where I was going.
And I ended up getting
taken to the family court.
And that there was
a petition filed,
a PINS petition at the time.
And it was just
so chaotic that I
had no idea what was happening.
I just thought, well, I
must have committed a crime.
I must have done something
wrong because I'm
in the back of this car.
And that just continued on
from age 14 on until 18.
And I just kept going
back and forth to court.
Also in school, I was
considered homeless
because I didn't live at home.
And I was actually kicked out
of three different high schools.
And it was very chaotic.
And people in the
school district
didn't understand
why I was acting out.
I was disrupting class.
I was disrupting everything
that came into my path,
I just destroyed
it because I didn't
have any support at home.
And everything seemed that
it was fine from the outside,
but no one was asking
those questions to find out
what was really going on.
And there was, at
the time, there
is a probation officer stationed
in the school district.
And she would-- full uniform,
school resource officer is what
they're called now--
and she would come to class,
make sure I was in class.
And all my classmates
thought that I was a problem.
No one wanted to
hang out with me.
My friends, their
parents wouldn't
allow them to hang out with me
because I was a problem child.
So that continued,
and eventually I
ended up in independent living.
So when I turned 16, I was
eligible to go to this group
home with other girls.
And I started
experimenting with drugs.
I was smoking weed.
I mean I just wanted
some kind of escape,
some kind of release, because
I didn't feel any connection
to anyone, not even to myself.
And then family court, going
back and forth to court
during that time,
the legal aid who
was supposed to be
representing me didn't ask me,
what do you want?
What's going on, or
what's going on at home?
Or where do you want to go?
So I just kind of cycled
through the system.
And when I aged out at
18, there was no plan.
There was no nowhere
for me to go.
It was just like, well, you've
aged out of this system.
And now we're just going to
leave you to your own devices.
And what ended up
happening was, because I
had no relationship with my
family, that wasn't reconciled,
all those years from
14 to 18, I ended up
moving in with a
boyfriend of mine.
And by the time I turned
19, actually seven years
to the day, I was arrested
for my part in a robbery.
And I was tried as an adult.
And I served time in jail.
And it's just been all
those missed opportunities
from when I was younger.
And it just seemed
so simple now,
when I look back on it,
that all somebody had
to do was ask me what
is going on with you?
Or how can we help you?
Or how can we support you?
And that simple question could
have changed the trajectory
of my whole life.
And it's just been such a
struggle now from being a girl
and now being an adult woman
with this felony conviction.
And it's been so
challenging to find a job.
And I'm not representative
of the population of girls
that are in the system.
I mean it
disproportionately affects
women and girls of color.
And I feel like it's a
responsibility that I have
and that I hope that those
listening and those here
today can understand that
we have a responsibility
to speak out about it, because
it's the only way that we're
going to change the hearts
and minds of people that
can make decisions.
And yeah, so it's
just been challenging.
If we can change things from the
front door, which is the girls'
system, then that would help.
[APPLAUSE]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: I want to
talk about this piece more,
that each of you has
given voice to of--
nobody asked me
what was going on.
I've spent many, many
moments and hours and days
in girls' correctional
facilities.
And I remember the first time
I went, I thought, my gosh,
they're just girls.
They're just hurt,
abused, violated girls.
Right?
[APPLAUSE]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: And I
want to understand better.
Can you help me to
understand better?
Why is it that the system feels
so comfortable just putting
the girls behind bars, than
asking that question of what's
going on?
CHARITY CHANDLER-COLE: Well, I
think for girls, just overall,
we're just looked at differently
in the criminal justice system.
People fail to realize
that when we offend,
it's normally because of
something we experienced
in our life prior
to the offense,
either through bad parenting
or poverty or lack of education
or being abused.
And that when we offend,
it's usually out of survival.
So it's usually something
we've stolen or we've acted out
or because we were actually
victims of something,
such as sex trafficking
or exploitation or even
domestic violence.
And when they look at us as
women, because even as girls,
we still are nurturers.
We still help to provide for
our family and for our siblings,
so when we offend
versus when boys offend,
we should have
known better, and we
deserve the punishment we
received, as opposed to boys--
oh, they're just
youthful and immature.
And when we are charged
for our offenses,
ours are gender-specific
offenses versus--
and so because they're
gender-specific offenses,
were perceived differently
and judged differently
and treated differently once
we're in the criminal justice
system.
Because what gets us in jail
versus what gets boys in jail,
they don't really know
how to deal with that.
So they just look at us as being
just bad, or we're acting out,
or we're whores, because
we were sexually exploited
or whatever the case.
So we should be treated
as such, instead
of realizing that we're more
vulnerable, we're more fragile,
we need more help because
we're susceptible,
more susceptible to
violence, and to be
being treated differently.
So it's just a
totally different lens
because of what we're
because of our offenses.
It's just different.
And we often go to jail
for nonviolent offenses.
And we get these crazy
ridiculous charges
for something that's
minimal and something
that, had someone taken
the time to say, you know,
what's going on?
Why are you 14, in
jail, for prostitution?
You know the first thing I saw
when I went to juvenile hall,
even though that
wasn't my charge,
was that there were
so many girls in here
locked up for having
sex with adult men.
I was blown away.
And at no point, did anyone
say what's happening?
You're being exploited.
You're being victimized.
No, they were criminalized.
And were constantly being
criminalized for things
that we should be looked
at as ways to help us,
and that's just not happening.
MICHELLE DIAZ:
Well, I do believe
that people don't
get to the root
of the causes of the problems.
We put, let's say,
we have to talk
about who are the real
expertise on these.
Like is it a book?
Who's going to teach you?
Like, what is it going
to be about in there?
And now, of course, now
we need to put the youth,
we need to put the people, and
nothing about us without us,
you know?
Who are the ones who are going
to come up with the solutions?
Because we experienced
what is the problem.
And of course, we have all these
amazing people that come here.
It goes to the [INAUDIBLE]
centers or whatever.
And they have no
idea they don't know
what is it like to be there.
And most importantly, the
people that come up with ideas
or go to these places, and
when you end up in a facility,
we have seen people be
treated differently.
People, kids, who have been
intimidated by the staff.
And you know, like when
you are in a facility
once a month, once
whatever, you--
the staff are there
for safety reasons.
But are you able
to speak freely?
Of course not.
Why?
Because you get
there, and you leave.
No, I'm stayed there.
And if I say something wrong,
what is going to happen next?
SARAH ZARBA: I just
wanted to make a point
that-- a status offense.
So when I was actually
detained, like,
a status offense is
something-- it's not a crime.
And it's because of
your status as a minor
that the action
becomes criminalized.
And that's what
happened, that's how
I started when I became
involved with the system,
running away from home
and skipping school.
I was placed in
handcuffs, and I was
placed in a detention
facility in a jail cell
because I skipped school.
And I think people don't realize
that that's what we do here.
I mean we really
take a hard look
at the practices
and the policies
that we have that affect girls
and just all kids in general.
We should not be locking up
kids for skipping school.
And that experience,
and not asking children,
because that's
what we're talking,
we're talking about
children, what
the reasons behind
their actions are.
And you know, I
remember just being
the only girl in the facility.
And I spent a lot of
times, I mean, isolated.
Because we need to be separated
from the boys, and just
there's always this
notion to protect girls.
And we need all this protection.
And that was not helpful,
because the protection that's
offered is punitive.
And it really damaged the
rest of my trajectory.
So I think it's
important to listen.
And there's a lot of
assumptions that are made,
I think at different
system points.
When you're in court, the
assumption is made by the judge
that the legal aid has talked
about this with the kid
or with the child.
And that's not what
happened to me.
So yeah, I think we just
need to start implementing
that every system point.
MICHELLE DIAZ: Can I
add something to it?
So I do believe that we are
being put in the menu and not
at the table.
Yeah.
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Being put on
the menu and not at the table.
MICHELLE DIAZ: Yeah.
Unfortunately, what could be
a whole day of conversation
on girls, and we need to have
a whole day on conversations
around girls because of
the systematic negligence
that is being
shown to our girls.
We have to give the stage over
to Kat Blaque and Maui Chacon.
But I wanted to so
deeply thank you
for being the young women,
the young fierce warrior
advocates for other girls
who are behind bars.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
KAT BLAQUE: Hello.
I just wanted to thank you
guys so much for inviting me
to introduce our next speaker.
My name is Kat, and
I've been a YouTuber
since I was a young teenager.
YouTube has been a very
central place in my life,
and it's really been
where I've always
come to express the
things that have
happened in my life, the
good, the bad, and the ugly.
And unfortunately,
while I had my platform,
I experienced sexual violence.
And because YouTube had
been such an integral part
of my life.
It was where I turned
to express my trauma.
And that didn't go very well.
I was told, almost immediately,
that I had made up the story.
That I had told the
story for views.
That I had fabricated
it, because after all,
who would want to
rape someone like me?
And so I internalized that.
I deleted my videos.
And for a really long time,
I didn't talk about it.
But once I gained the strength
to speak about it again,
I realized just how much
rape and sexual violence
is a tool of silence.
Just how much it is used against
women and people, in general,
to silence them and to stop them
from being able to get justice.
That rape culture
relies on this silence.
And that social
media, especially,
is an amazing place for us to be
able to come forward and speak.
And when I started
telling my story,
I got contacted by women who
had similar stories, who said
that my story reflected theirs.
And we all said to
each other the words
that we all needed to hear so
badly, that we believed you.
So social media has been a very
important part of my activism
and what I do.
We've seen so many good and
positive things come out
of raising voices.
And a lot of the women
today, those that spoke,
are leaving me wanting to have
conversations on my platform
to draw attention to
a lot of the things
that I didn't know about
were happening to our women
and girls.
Our next speaker is going
to be Maui Chacon, who
is a woman who has
been using her poetry
to fight against women who are
being who are being trafficked.
So I just wanted to
introduce Maui Chacon.
[APPLAUSE]
MAUI CHACON: Hi, guys.
OK.
So yeah, I was trafficked at 12.
Thank you.
So I wrote this poem
when I was 13 years old.
I just wanted to give
you guys a mind frame
of where I was at the time.
Am I walking through hell or
beneath the shadows of death?
I need someone to help me.
I'm like a baby
crying for a nipple,
like a dog wanting it's owner.
Beautiful on the outside,
but feel degraded,
misused, and ugly on the inside.
Why no one love me for me?
Pushing people away because they
act as if they care, like Tupac
with his mistress love affair?
Have a soul of steel, a heart
as flimsy as a bird's feather,
like a tiger hunted for prey,
but a mind frame of a baby cub,
on the level of a great boat and
have a spark out of this world.
And I have dreams,
but what is that?
I want to help people
because I need help.
I reach out to people because
no one reached out to me.
I'm living alone with
no honesty and existing
in this world with no dignity.
They say I have a purpose.
But what might that be?
I want to be like Sleeping
Beauty, hopefully wake up
in someone else's
body that's not me.
I keep asking who might that be?
I want to be like
Pink, how she's
so energetic and so sweet.
Like [INAUDIBLE]
crying like a puppy,
acting out like Angelina
Jolie, Mr. and Mrs. Smith,
beating myself up.
Not me, but the inside of me.
They say I act out
because of my ADHD.
I'm going to be me.
Learn to sit up like a baby.
Better yet, trying
to come out a cocoon,
hopefully one day, or maybe.
Picking that cheese,
like a baby mice,
like a caged bird
screaming for food.
Is it bad that my mind seeks
the gates of hell, or wonders
for a black night?
Why can't I have
someone hold me tight?
I look at my reflection,
and yet my body
starts to feel cold, like
a polar bear in winter
but a vampire at night.
Katrina washing people
away and I'm trying
to find that secret get away.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Wow.
Thank you, Maui, for
sharing your words.
The poem speaks for itself.
But I just feel so incredibly
privileged to be in this room.
And thank all of you for
sharing your stories.
Just-- we're so privileged to
have you here at Google today.
For those of you that I haven't
met, my name is [INAUDIBLE].
And I'm a program
manager at Google.org,
which is the philanthropic
arm of Google.
And I support our
racial justice work.
So I've been incredibly
moved by everything
I've heard today
and also reminded
of sort of where we've
started this work as Google
and how far it's come.
So I wanted to share a
little bit of that story
and reflect back to when
we began our racial justice
funding at Google back in 2014.
And we were, to be
honest, curiously
optimistic about
where it would lead.
Like many folks in the
room, there are definitely
Googlers who have been
impacted by the system
of mass incarceration, who have
parents and family members who
are incarcerated today, and
many of these Googlers advocate
and volunteer with criminal
justice organizations
in their personal time.
But working on the
giving team at Google,
we were trying to
move this issue
to the center of our
company's consciousness
and to bring it to
a place where we
could open that conversation
to those who may not
feel as proximate to the issue.
And so I remember the day that
my colleague, Justin Steele,
got the signal
from our executives
to present our initial work
in this area at our company
meeting.
And Malika referenced it at
the beginning of our day.
But it's a big meeting.
Googlers from all
over the world tune
in on GBC, which is our kind
of virtual way to connect.
And the room isn't that much
bigger than this one here,
but we knew that thousands of
Googlers would be listening.
And it was our way to kind
test out Googlers' willingness
to get close to the issue.
And I remember, on the back end,
calling our community partners
and letting them know, many of
them who we're now supporting
through our grants,
that this work
was going to be talked about
during our company meeting.
And I actually didn't share
how big that meeting was,
so they might think it
was just a couple of folks
who were interested in
hearing more about their work.
But the response from
Googlers that day,
and to this day, Googlers who
are challenging themselves
to learn more about this issue
and supporting the folks that
have boots on the
ground, it really
inspires us on our team to
keep moving the company forward
and challenging ourselves
to discuss this conversation
and push where we
haven't pushed before.
So our employees have
hosted movie screenings
on mass incarceration,
both on campus
and in the community; policy
convenings, like today,
on criminal justice; brought
some of the nation's most
prominent speakers and
voices in the movement,
folks like Brian Stevenson and
Gina Clayton to our campus;
and are volunteering in the
communities and in prisons.
And we think that's
very important.
We're very excited now to
be testing out Googlers
actually getting on the
ground, in the office,
and working alongside one
of our community partners,
Center for Policing Equity
to engineer systems and help
build a national database
that can help reduce bias
in policing.
And so I just wanted
to share with the room
that we're pushing ourselves
to get smarter and do more.
And I want to
encourage everyone who
is listening from the
company side on the GBC today
to really just continue your
volunteering, your giving,
and learn more about this issue.
And as we are challenged today,
make an intentional effort
to support and share our
platform with women and girls
who are directly impacted.
You can go to go/getproximate,
if you're listening in,
to get involved with
our volunteering efforts
at Google.org in
criminal justice.
And then for the folks
who are in the room,
let's please find
ways to collaborate.
If you have a creative idea on
how we can share our platforms,
please find me after this event.
Or you can reach out to me.
My email address
is maab@google.org.
And you can learn more about our
criminal justice grant-making
efforts at www.Google.org.
So thank you all for sharing
this room with us today,
and for sharing your
voices and your stories.
We really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: I
really thank everybody
for being with us today.
And I want to give
special thanks
and honor to the women and
girls who not only shared
their narratives, but also
their expertise of how
we dismantle these
pipelines into incarceration
for women and girls.
I also want to say
to those in the room
and those who are listening in,
that one powerful way of being
part of this movement to
make sure that our women
and girls are not
left behind, is
to know what the National
Council for Formerly
Incarcerated and Incarcerated
Women and Girls is up to.
If you go to their
website, you can find out
how to donate to them as well
as be part of the campaigns
that they are advancing.
I also want to plead to make
sure that we, as a company,
continue to be
proximate, continue
to recognize that this issue
is at the center of all
of our work and
communities and lives.
That it is not marginal.
That it is part of how
we can use our goodness,
and use our wisdom, and use
our platforms to make sure
that we live in a society
where everyone is valued,
where every life, where every
mother-child bond is honored
and has the chance to be.
And finally, I want
to close this out
on two notes of gratitude.
Gratitude to Topeka Sam for
helping us bring the women in.
[APPLAUSE]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: We have
to keep thinking about ways
to use tech to scale
the prison walls.
And we tried to do that today.
And thank you, Topeka,
for helping us to do that,
to bring the voices of
Miss Alice and Miss Santra
into our space.
And I also want to
give special thanks
to Greer Stockman who allowed
this all to come together.
[APPLAUSE]
MALIKA SAADA SAAR: Thank you
for all of the courage that
was shown today.
And we are going to close out
with Christen Lien, allowing
us to just breathe
in this moment,
and think how we are
going to move forward
in the work before us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTEN LIEN: Hi, everyone.
There's two songs I want
to play for you today
that I think are very fitting.
And before I do, while I set
up and tune my instrument
over here, anyone that's away
in the distance, feels far away,
and wants to come
over to this side,
we'll have a second
for you to do that.
The first song I want to
play is called "The Escape."
And it's from an album that's
coming out later this year.
And this song, this
single actually,
is going to drop on Thursday.
So you guys are hearing
it before everyone else.
And it's called "The
Escape" because my new album
is about a character
who escapes a prison.
And I wrote this song
not just about escaping
a physical prison, but the kind
that we impose on ourselves
in terms of the kind of
self-love we give ourselves,
or how we allow other
people to dictate who we are
and what we can be.
So I hope you enjoy it.
And then I'll explain
the second song here.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - CHRISTEN LIEN - "THE
ESCAPE"]
CHRISTEN LIEN: Thank you.
Thank you so much for everyone
sharing stories today.
It has just been
an incredible day.
And leads me to why I want
to play this next song that I
wrote, called "Unconditional."
And I call it
"Unconditional" because I
wanted to write a song
that captured the essence
of unconditional love.
Not just any kind of
love, but unconditional--
it's the kind that loves you
not only in your best moments,
but your worst
moments, you know?
The kind of love
that accepts you
for who you are, including the
highest version of yourself,
and then that monster
that comes out sometimes
that we're ashamed of,
but is a part of us.
The stories of our lives
that we can't be without,
because as hard as
they are, they made us.
They are us.
So I wanted to see if
I could write a song,
even without lyrics, that could
capture that feeling of what
it means to be unconditionally
loved for those of us who
know that feeling.
Because even though everyone
deserves unconditional love,
not everyone has it.
So I thought if I could
capture it in a song,
we could all share it.
Thank you.
[MUSIC - CHRISTEN LIEN,
"UNCONDITIONAL"]
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTEN LIEN: Thank you.